Shoto has fallen Eda has fallen Hawks is
barely standing in quirkless and many of
our favorite heroes are being consumed
by the fire of this Final War Sad Man's
parade is devouring Heroes left and
right and this could be it for many of
the heroes unless ochako can stop toga
right here and now but it gets worse
much much worse with so many Heroes
already being taken out of the fight by
the villains the two most important
villains all for one in shigaraki are
about to have a disturbingly clear path
to victory was this part of all for
one's master plan all along let's get
into it you guys know the drill if you
enjoy our major content and you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment right now it only takes
you a second but it helps me with that
YouTube algorithm and over 50 of you
guys watch my videos regularly are not
subscribed to the channel remember that
subscribing is completely free and it
helps me out a lot finally this video
will contain mha manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the previous chapter
Shoto managed to stop Dobby from blowing
up and taking out his entire family in
the process Shoto used his ultimate
attack flash fire fist phosphor great
glacial agier and yeah that's a mouthful
and with the help of the powerful ice
quirks used by his mother and two other
siblings he managed to cool down the
entire Battlefield with what can only be
described as like an ice explosion when
all was said and done Shoto was still
standing they fumi and Natsu are injured
but alive and dabian Endeavor are lying
on the ground Dobby's Flames have been
extinguished and he is now little more
than a charred corpse but he is still
not dead at least not yet and never then
apologized to every member of his family
individually almost like he was saying
final goodbye to all of them before
dying the last chapter Ended as toga
looked towards the battlefield where
Dobby was fighting and seemingly implied
that he had just died but of course
there was no confirmation of Dobby's
death she may just think he died because
his Flames were extinguished and to be
fair he does look very close to death
but this is a Shonen Series so you
cannot assume that anyone is dead until
you actually see the dead body and
people are actually acknowledging that
the person is dead and even then it's
still not 100 certain so we can't jump
to conclusions unfortunately the latest
chapter doesn't give us any definitive
death confirmations although we do get
to see some of the aftermath of the
Dobby battle including disturbing images
of Shoto and Hawks but more on that
later first we have to talk about toga
and Sad Man's parade because that fight
is still raging and toga is continuing
to create more and more twice clones
without an end in sight toga is
convinced that all heroes must die and
she is mercilessly attempting to game
end all of them we see that multiple Pro
heroes are struggling to survive amidst
the never-ending onslaught of twice
clones including Pixie bob and tiger
from the wild wild pussycat up to this
point Pixie bob had been using her
powerful earth-bending Quirk to keep the
army of clones at Bay but at this point
we see her being overtaken by the clones
and tiger is very worried not only for
her safety but also he knows that
without her Quirk there's going to be no
way of containing Sad Man's parade you
get the feeling that the heroes are
falling to Sad Man's parade one by one
and if the real toga isn't defeated soon
the heroes will lose this battle just
like they lost the battle against all
for one the heroes know that toga's time
limit for how long she can keep using
twice as Quirk depends on how much of
his blood she was able to consume but
there is no way to know just how much
blood she consumed and so there is no
way to know how long Sad Man's parade is
actually going to last as of right now
there is no indication that toga is
gonna stop anytime soon and the heroes
know that even a single mistake in this
battle could lead to all of them
literally drowning in an endless stream
of clones in a matter of seconds we then
get a brief glimpse of the aftermath of
the battle with Dobby and we see that
Shoto has dropped to the ground and lost
Consciousness we also see Ida who is
injured and exhausted in the middle of
the street and we see Hawks who is
standing alone with a blade in his hand
and he too looks like a Walking Corpse
he is severely injured and absolutely
exhausted and it is clear that he is
barely standing kudos to him for getting
back up on his feet but with how injured
he is and seeing how he no longer even
has his Quirk I don't know how much he
can actually do now I mean I respect him
for getting up but unless you can find
some sort of healing potion I think he
will remain off the board for the
foreseeable future and speaking of
Heroes who are off the board remember
bakugo guys whatever happened to him
anyway back in the battle against toga
ocheko is still fighting fiercely as the
twice clones command her to Die the real
toga is wondering whether Toya also died
and left her behind just like twice did
and ochako manages to locate her and
grab a hold of her with her wrist rope
thingy well that's not the technical
term but you know what I mean they're
like those grappling hooks that she
releases from her wrist support items
that allow her to grab onto things and
people ochiko then tries to talk to Toca
once again because she knows that when
they talked before she kind of just
dismissed toga as a villain who needed
to stop hurting innocent people she is
now trying to relate to toga more in
order to calm her down and she says that
she knows that toga has been crying and
that she is not just some heartless evil
monster ocheko says that she thinks she
knows why toga has been unable to fully
become twice and actually use the quirks
of the other people she cares about
including
believes that it's not because toga
doesn't love Dobby and shigaraki rather
it's because toga has mixed her pure
feelings of love for her friends with
her murderous intent towards the heroes
and this has diluted the purity of her
love put simply toga is trying to become
her friends and use their powers for the
sole purpose of getting revenge against
the heroes but that means she isn't
really doing it for love anymore she is
essentially trying to use her love for
her friends to make herself into a more
effective mass murderer but that's not
how love works love is supposed to be
pure and selfless it's not supposed to
be a means to achieving a specific end
and especially not such a dark and
violent end in short toga's obsession
with Revenge has clouded the purity of
her love for her friends this Theory
seems to strike a chord with toga
because she suddenly becomes Furious and
the twice mask begins to slip from her
face she says you shut your mouth
what could you possibly understand about
me but ocheko understands that she must
be on to something because toga is
clearly reacting to her words and she
seems to be turning back into toga again
even though up to this point she had
just been blending in with the other
clones
this is ochako's chance to face off
against toga the real toga once and for
all I think that ochako has figured out
something important here even though she
is a psycho who doesn't understand why
doing bad things to other people is
wrong toga does have genuine feelings of
love for her friends and she doesn't
like those feelings being evaluated and
questioned by ochako she also doesn't
think that someone is selfless and
heroic as ochako could ever understand
her and what she had gone through as a
complete Outcast who was rejected by
Society due to her socially unacceptable
Behavior but maybe ochako can get inside
the mind of toga at least long enough to
play some seeds of Doubt into toga's
plan to kill all the heroes ochako knows
that if she doesn't stop toga Right Here
and Now many Heroes and hero students
will be trampled to death by the twice
clothes so ochako has to find a way to
stop this if she can't stop it
physically by overpowering all the Clone
bones then she has to stop it
psychologically by confusing toga and
making her doubt herself and as things
stand now this toga fight will likely
end soon one way or the other and then
we will finally get to see the last two
battles All For One versus all might and
Deku vs shigaraki with all these massive
battles reaching their conclusion in the
recent chapters I've been starting to
think that things might actually be
going according to all for one's master
plan I mean think about it all for one
decisively won the big fight at goonga
and in the process he took a bunch of
extremely powerful Heroes and hero
students off the board this includes the
number two Pro Hero Hawks as well as
Mount lady tokuyami and many more as far
as the Dobby fight goes he lost to Shoto
in the end but from the looks of it both
Shoto and the number one Pro Hero
Endeavor have also been taken off the
board as a result of this fight along
with Eda just for Goodman measure now
the toga fight is reaching its climax
but by the end of it we can assume that
many of the heroes there and the hero
students from shikitsu will also be
unable to continue fighting even if they
win in the end most of them will be too
injured and too exhausted to continue
the war so that means that all for one
and shigaraki are going to have far
fewer Heroes to deal with than they did
before so in that sense all for one and
shikiraki are progressing towards
Victory I mean if all for one can take
out all might then shikaraki can take
out Deku there really won't be that many
Heroes and hero students left to oppose
them and even if a bunch are left they
won't be strong enough to do so so this
war could still go either way if we step
back and look at the war objectively the
heroes have taken out some important
villains but they're not exactly winning
we are still far away from a happy
Shonen ending that most of us are
expecting what do you guys think is the
war actually going according to all for
one's master plan or do you think that
the heroes have the advantage how will
the toga and ochako Showdown end and who
will be left standing in the end finally
what will happen in the final two
battles the battles against all for one
in shigaraki let me know down below if
you guys enjoyed this video and you want
to see more mha content in the future
leave a quick like right now and if you
are one of the over 50 of people who
watch my videos regularly but haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
huge favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
Bell to turn on all notifications
subscribing on YouTube is completely
free it only takes a few seconds but it
means a lot for the channel thank you in
advance you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at animeoproar as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys